we're told alejandro was curious if
sample median was an unbiased estimator
of population median he placed ping pong
balls numbered from 0 to 32 so i guess
that would be what 33 ping pong balls in
a drum and mix them well
note that the median of the population
is 16 right the median number of course
yes in that population is 16.
he then took a random sample of five
balls and calculated the median of the
sample so we have this population of
balls he takes a we know the population
parameter we know that the population
median
is 16
but then he starts taking a sample of
five balls so n equals five and he
calculates a sample median
sample
median
and then he replaced the balls and
repeated this process for a total of 50
trials
his results are summarized in the dot
plot below where each dot represents the
sample median from a sample of five
balls so he does this he takes these
five balls puts them back in then he
does it again then he does it again and
every time he calculates the sample
median for that sample and he plus that
on the dot plot so and he'll do this for
50 samples
and each dot here represents that sample
statistic so it shows that four times we
got a sample median in four of those 50
samples we got a sample median of 20. in
five of those sample medians we got a
sample median of 10.
and so what he ends up creating with
these dots is really an approximation of
the sampling distribution of the sample
medians
now to judge whether it is a biased or
unbiased estimator for the population
median well actually pause the video see
if you can figure that out
all right now let's do this together now
to judge it let's think about where the
true population parameter is the
population median it's 16. we know that
and so that is right over here the true
population parameter
so if we were dealing with a biased a
biased estimator for the population
parameter
then as we get our approximation of the
sampling distribution we would expect it
to be somewhat skewed so for example if
the sampling if this approximation of
the sampling distribution looks
something like that then we said okay
that looks like a biased estimator or if
it was looking something like that we'd
say okay that looks like a biased
estimator but if this approximation for
our sampling distribution that alejando
is constructing where we see that
roughly the same proportion of the
sample statistics came out below as came
out above the true parameter and it's
not doesn't have to be exact but it
seems roughly the case this seems pretty
unbiased and so to answer the question
based on these results it does appear
that the sample median is an unbiased
estimator of the population median